for 10 years it's been like hallowed
ground yesterday relatives and friends
came back to Ground Zero to revere the
dead but today for the first time since
the attacks the site will be open to the
public Deborah Berlin games brother was
the pilot of flight 77 that was crashed
into the Pentagon by the hijackers she
says Americans should be allowed to
connect physically with ground zero I
have never felt that 911 or any of the
sacred ground where my brother and other
the victims were killed belong to the
families and the families alone the
American people were pretty magnificent
that day and I feel they they own this
as much as we do across the country
Americans kept faith with their pledge
never to forget on the first sunday of
the american football season a huge
stars and stripes was unfurled in
chicago by the city's first responders
who traced to new york on the day of the
attacks
across town from ground zero a British
ceremony honored the dead a weekend of
remembrance was concluded in Washington
by President Obama our belief in America
born of a timeless ideal that men and
women should govern themselves that all
people are created equal and deserve the
same freedom to determine their own
destiny that belief through tests and
trials has only been strengthened these
past 10 years have shown that America
does not give in to fear 400,000 people
have registered to visit ground zero and
it's Memorial Plaza last night two
pillars of light rose out of Manhattan
ghostly reminders of what once stood
here but also beacons of hope soaring
above this guard skyline Dominic Waghorn
Sky News New York